le petit émilie est toujours introuvable
l'enfant de 2 ans et demi a disparu au
Verney il y a près de deux jours les
cabanes ont été passées au peigne fin
quasiment toutes les maisons du hameau
ont été visitées par les gendarmes avec
l'autorisation des habitants malgré
toutes ces recherches nous n'avons pas
pu alors où je vous parle localiser
l'enfant 150 pages eau vitriol dans le
rapport que publie la Ligue des droits
de l'Homme l'organisation pointe la
tactique de maintien de l'ordre lors des
événements de sainte Soline que vous
savez depuis combien de temps ce slogan
il chantait dans les manifestation vous
allez dans les manifestations vous les
couvrez parfois vous l'entendez tout le
temps sans doute depuis longtemps
heureusement là c'est là vous avez
remarqué que parce que moi je me
reconnais pas dans ce slogan donc vous
avez remarqué comme eu des gros plans
que je n'ai pas exprime est-ce que
comment ça se fait comment se fait
comment se fait ce que c'est maintenant
le sujet une journée à attendre en vain
des regrets des responsables de la nupes
qui défilent dans une manifestation
interdite au cri de tout le monde
déteste la police quelle tristesse pour
la République et pour les femmes et les
hommes qu'il a défendent adepte des
formules chocs Gérald Darmanin ancien la
parole de Nicolas Sarkozy serait-il le
petit voyou du gouvernement comme le
désigne un collaborateur d'Emmanuel
Macron dans le journal Libération une
chose est sûre selon le quotidien le
locataire de la Place Beauvau s'active
pour devenir Premier ministre l'état
manque à son obligation première qui est
de garantir l'exercice du droit de
manifester dans des conditions de
sécurité un ministre de l'Intérieur très
ambitieux qui joue avec les nerfs de sa
patronne
j'aime bien faire la bise à Borne parce
que je sais que ça l'emmerde le rôle
d'une police républicaine on ne le
répétera jamais assez et de protéger les
citoyens et non de les violentés c'est
qu'on a que du sale telle une pinata
géante
et qu'on soit
ici présent muni d'énormes pâtes avec
des clous au bout comme dans Klock
orange tu vois après les émeutes l'usage
de mortier d'artifice est réservé aux
seuls professionnels afin de limiter
tout débordement mais ce décret
d'interdiction vaut pour la France mais
pas pour la Belgique or de l'autre côté
de la frontière certains revendeurs
voient affluer les clients et on aurait
tous
notre micro et dans un feu de Bengal de
joie de servir et de sang
on le foutrait à terme mais gentiment tu
vois j'avance d'essayer de nous en
procurer sur les réseaux sociaux les
revendeurs sont nombreux nous les avons
contactés et nous sommes rendus sur
place en caméra cachée il n'y a pas
d'apaisement et Emmanuel Macron face à
un conflit social a toujours la même
méthode c'est à dire de durcir de
renvoyer et d'appliquer un autoritarisme
supplémentaire de faire un peu pardon de
le dire comme ça mais le Kakou
une vente rapide la seconde fois c'est
un enfant d'environ 10 ans qui nous a
lui-même donné des mortis en main propre
le tabloïde britannique The Sun qui a
révélé l'affaire vendredi dernier le
journal publie le témoignage d'une mère
de famille elle accuse un présentateur
vedette de la BBC d'avoir donné
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de livres
sterling à son enfant alors âgé de 17
ans en échange de photos
pédopornographiques
ce sont des publications cnews c'est
très clairement l'exemple ils font du
mal à démocratie moi je pense qu'ils
font du mal à aller les démocratie aucun
doute moi je suis vous savez donc je
considère je considère que lutter contre
l'extrême droite c'est une priorité ça
peut se faire de toutes les manières
possibles d'un ministre quel que soit le
ministre devrait s'interdire de toute
façon de porter des jugements globaux
sur des médias quels qu'ils soient c'est
pas le rôle d'un ministre et en plus
bien évidemment c'est toujours
caricatural vous pouvez pas quel que
soit le média
comme ça le résumé en deux mots et en
deux mots qui ont chacun 16 sont
infamant c'est rendu à Windsor cet
après-midi pour y rencontrer Charles III
après avoir vu le premier ministre
riches una qui s'est ensuite envolée
pour le sommet de l'OTAN en Lituanie